allez venez monde alessandra moi je fais
tout ce que vous voulez alessandra je
sais même pas ce qu'on va faire c'est
vraiment vous arrivez sur des beats on
dirait aujourd'hui on va commencer par
une petite action collective d'accord et
dac
donc je vais appeler l'assistant comme
dans l'émission pour m'apporter le
premier objet de l'action collective
mais c'est d'y aller
j'aime bien cette action collective
s'adresse à vos chroniques un bel air où
la fille sont comme ça les secteurs
alimentation je les vends j'ai beaucoup
d'animateurs qui dans cette émission
était parfois sert d'un petit peu et
influent c'est simple vous allez avoir
chacun votre tour le choix de prendre un
oeuf et de le taper sur la tête d'un oui
il y en a des durs et des mous et ya des
durs j'adore
ils n'ont pas le droit de les toucher
alors nyse le tout ils le prennent
voilà c'est ça alors alessandra est ok
matthieu delormeau on va démarrer
parfois j'adore ce style c'est ce qui
fait que m du coup mais si la personne a
maintenant comme ça d'accord oui ça
manquait les inquiéter je paie nature je
précède il ya bien eu agression c'est
pas la peine alors alors on y va pas
chez la société de production chd oh oui
la mienne c'est max motion d'accord te
propose la maxe battle h2o d'accord ait
une bataille
tout simple comme quand on joue et quand
on était gamins à chaque fois que l'un
d'eux nous père il prend un verre d'eau
il prend un verre d'eau dans la gueule
d'un cas si on fait égalité
il a bataillé on prend celui-là c'est
exact ivement la petite car j'adore si
c'est lui qui a fini ses verres en
premier aura le droit de quoi à une méga
surprise pour l'autre à attendant je
regarde derrière des trois jeux they
kiss my own
[Applaudissements]
c'est bon j'ai compris qu'elle a compris
xynthia
[Musique]
alors t'as pas trop fort au moment où tu
mets vins
[Applaudissements]
j'adore j'adore
apparu
est-ce qu'on avait la burqa voir
d'abaisser non pas sur les cheveux longs
ballons pour isabelle bon dieu attention
la plus parfaite
elle a pété la tête à la beauté de
l'être
[Applaudissements]
j'aime bien ce jeune gars n a guère
attention
1 2 3
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
attention aux mondiaux
[Applaudissements]
nada
si je gagne ici derrière tant sûr tu
prend cher soit au qatar où ce calme
focal il est fabien je rappelle qu'elle
est en pleine arrivée l'ex batteur h2o
attention l âme soeur rebbie
d'après moi non tu m'en donnes à l'ena
cgt calmer alors attend maintenant les
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
2/3 aux punaises dans la carte de merde
[Applaudissements]
non
j
cg
[Applaudissements]
à pour touba
c'est la partie
[Applaudissements]
oui
f